Your new favorite show, House of the Dragon,
Game of Thrones Prequel series is currently
filming and is coming in 2022 on HBO.
Based on George RR Martin’s book Fire And
Blood, it tells the story of the Dance of
the Dragons, a Targaryen civil war of succession
between Aegon II and his half-sister Rhaenyra
over their father Viserys I's throne.
These days you are able to see many House
of the Dragon set photos, which serve as a
little promo or tease for what is about to
come.
Rhaenyra Targaryen and Daemon Targaryen are
the only characters we see in these photos.
Here you can see them filming on the set that’s
been in production for the past week on Holywell
Beach in Cornwall.
They are in full regal Targaryen costume.
They shared a scene, speaking together on
the beach, and once they finished their conversation,
Rhaenyra then walked towards the sea which
is when the scene ends.
Rhaenyra and Daemon are on Driftmark, the
seat of House Velayrion and this scene takes
place after the bloody Battle of the Gullet.
So who are these two characters?
Rhaenyra and Daemon are the main characters
of our story.
King Viserys’ chosen heir, a dragon rider
who grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, cheered as the
Realm's Delight when she was young and later
called the Half-Year Queen, was the first-born
child of King Viserys I Targaryen.
Rhaenyra was King Viserys I's only living
child by his first wife, Queen Aemma of House
Arryn.
At the age of eight she was made her father's
heir and grew up expecting to become the first
ruling Queen of Westeros.
Rhaenyra was a dragonrider whose mount was
Syrax.
Rhaenyra had her family's Valyrian looks,
wearing her silver-gold hair in a long braid
in the manner of Queen Visenya Targaryen.
Beautiful as a child, Rhaenyra was later declared
by her uncle, later husband and the man who
is standing beside her in these photos, Prince
Daemon Targaryen, to be the most beautiful
maiden in all the Seven Kingdoms.
Daemon Targaryen is also a key figure from
this time period and is George R.R. Martin's
favorite Targaryen.
Daemon Targaryen also known as Prince of the
City, Lord Flea Bottom and the Rogue Prince
had many titles throughout his life: Prince,
Ser, Commander of the City Watch, Master of
coin, master of laws, King of the stepstones
and the narrow sea, protector of the realm.
Daemon was the most contoversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventuer
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at a same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He was Rhaenyra's second husband, following
Ser Laenor Velaryon and she was his third
wife.
Prince Daemon was the most experienced warrior
of his time and wielded the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister.
A dragonrider whose dragon was Caraxes, Daemon
declared himself the King of the Stepstones
and the Narrow Sea.
Daemon was a skilled warrior, described in
the histories as dashing, daring, and dangerous.
He was also ambitious, impetuous, mercurial,
amoral, reckless, and quick to take offense.
He is described as being as charming as he
was hot-tempered.
Due to the lack of a male heir, Viserys designated
Rhaenyra as his successor.
Therefore, Rhaenyra was the only female Targaryen
to lay claim to the Iron Throne in her own
right.
Since she was raised as the designated heir,
Rhaenyra became quite pampered and arrogant,
but also gained practical governmental experience.
After Rhaenyra's mother died, her father remarried
and had several sons by his second wife, Alicent
of House Hightower.
Even so, Viserys still publicly expected his
daughter to succeed him, and when he died,
his official will even stated so.
However, Rhaenyra's younger half-brother,
Aegon, challenged her claim.
He stated that the normal inheritance laws
of the Andals (which formed the basis of the
unified law code in Westeros) called for male-preference
primogeniture, meaning that a younger son
would rightfully inherit before an older daughter.
Rhaenyra had 2 husbands and 5 sons.
Her fist husband was Laenor of House Velayrion,
son of the Sea Snake.
Laenor and Rhaenyra had three sons together:
Princes Jacaerys 'Jace', Lucerys 'Luke', and
Joffrey 'Joff' Velaryon.
All were near adulthood and had dragons of
their own when Rhaenyra's father, Viserys
I, died.
It was rumored that those sons of Rhaenyra's
were actually fathered by her champion and
lover, Harwin Strong, the strongest man in
Westeros, called "Breakbones", as all three
were born with brown hair and brown eyes,
though Laenor and Rhaenyra both had light
silver/gold hair and purple eyes.
The Greens were the ones who sparked this
ruomor, often calling them Strongs.
The true parentage of Rhaenyra's three eldest
children is still unclear.
The siblings Laenor and Laena Velaryon who
were married to Rhaenyra and Daemon Targaryen,
both died in 120 AC, as did Rhaenyra's alleged
lover, Breakbones.
Rhaenyra then secretly married her uncle,
Prince Daemon, the most experienced and the
most dangerous warrior of his time, at Dragonstone.
The news of their wedding caused a great scandal
at the court of King's Landing and made Rhaenyra's
father furious.
It took some time before Viserys and Daemon
reconciled.
Rhaenyra's other sons, Princes Aegon and Viserys
Targaryen, were fathered by Daemon and all
had Targaryen features.
At the time of her father's death, Rhaenyra
was on Dragonstone awaiting the birth of her
child.
The greens in King's Landing ensured that
the news of the Viserys's death did not reach
her until her own supporters in the Red Keep
were dead or imprisoned and Aegon II's coronation
had already occurred.
This began a devastating civil war that tore
apart the Seven Kingdoms, known as The Dance
of the Dragons, as it was the only war in
which both sides had dragonriders.
These scenes right here take place after the
bloodiest sea battle in Westeros history.
There is an upturned shipwrecked hull being
set up by carpenters on the location.
The presence of a leftover shipwreck as many
of you guessed correctly points to the Battle
of the Gullet.
The Battle of the Gullet, also called the
Battle in the Gullet, was a battle that took
place in the Gullet in 130 AC during the Dance
of the Dragons.
It remains among the bloodiest sea battles
in all of history.
House Velaryon blockaded the Gullet and controlled
access to Blackwater Bay at the start of the
civil war.
After the assault on Harrenhal by Prince Daemon
Targaryen and further blows to the greens,
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King to
Aegon II Targaryen, hatched a plan to break
the Velaryon fleet's blockade.
Otto reached out across the narrow sea to
enemies of Prince Daemon, the Triarchy, hoping
to persuade them to move against the Sea Snake,
Lord Corlys Velaryon.
Otto's plan took time and Aegon II eventually
ran out of patience with his grandfather's
prevarications, replacing him as Hand with
Ser Criston Cole.
The schemes of Otto eventually bore fruit,
as the High Council of the Triarchy accepted
his offer of alliance in Tyrosh.
Ninety warships, commanded swept from the
Stepstones under the banners of the Three
Daughters, bending their oars for the Gullet.
Meanwhile on Dragonstone, it was decided by
Prince Jacaerys Velaryon that his half-brothers,
Princes Aegon and Viserys Targaryen, would
be fostered with a Prince of Pentos until
their mother, Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen, had
secured the Iron Throne.
The princes departed on a ship, towards the
end of 129 AC.
The Sea Snake sent seven of his warships with
them as escort.
Their ships encountered the Triarchy's fleet,
which had sailed up to the Gullet.
It was taken captive and warships were sunk
or captured.
Possessed only of a dragon egg, Viserys had
no way of escaping from the ship and was made
captive.
Aegon escaped on his young dragon, Stormcloud.
Sailors attempted to bring them down and Stormcloud
was wounded by arrows and scorpion bolts.
Nevertheless, they flew to Dragonstone, where
Aegon delivered the news of the threat from
the east.
Stormcloud died at Dragonstone from his wounds.
The battle began on the fifth day of the new
year, 130 AC.
The Triarchy's ships divided into two squadrons
entering the Gullet to the north and south
of Dragonstone.
They attacked at sunrise, surprising House
Velaryon's fleet.
Flying on Vermax to meet the fleet of the
Triarchy, Prince Jacaerys Velaryon swept down
upon enemy galleys.
The sailors had experience fighting Prince
Daemon Targaryen and his dragon, Caraxes,
during the war for the Stepstones, so their
captains directed their spears and arrows
against Jacaerys.
One ship caught on fire and then another,
however.
When Jacaerys was joined by Ulf the White
on Silverwing, Nettles on Sheepstealer, Addam
Velaryon on Seasmoke, and Hugh Hammer on Vermithor,
the line of warships from the Free Cities
shattered as one galley after another turned
away.
Vermax flew too low, however, and crashed
down into the sea, possibly wounded from a
crossbow bolt to the eye or pulled down by
a grapnel.
Survivors said he struggled in the rigging
of a burning galley and sank with it.
Jacaerys leaped free, but was then killed
by Myrish crossbowmen.
North and south of Dragonstone the battle
continued into nighttime.
The southern squadron bypassed Dragonstone,
believing that it was too strong to assault,
and instead attacked Driftmark, setting afire
the harbor of Spicetown with fire ships.
The town was sacked, with its inhabitants
butchered.
The High Tide and the treasures of Lord Corlys
Velaryon were burned by Myrish and Tyroshi
soldiers, with the Sea Snake's servants cut
down as they fled.
These scenes here take place a day or two
after that as Rhaenyra and Daemon return to
see what's left of Driftmark, discussing their
next moves.
I hope these photos of Rhaenyra and Demon
Targaryen made you even more excited for the
upcoming epic Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon.
Thank you so much for watching and I hope
to see you in the next one.
Peace!